welcome rich vos hi guys hey a while I
know we're just talking about Jeff Bezos
opening his investigation for what he's
trying to find out who leaked the texts
that caused him to get divorced you know
he's texting this chick nobody wants to
know who babbled like I wants to know
who leaked it to the press I did I just
confessed myself
everybody's trying yeah we're all trying
to get on the money trying to get the
cash
yeah well that's so they're trying to
figure out is it politically motivated
they think you know because Trump
obviously doesn't like Jeff Bezos uh-huh
and so they're going and it was broken
in the Enquirer the guy runs Enquirer is
connected to Trump so they're trying to
figure out if that was part of it
well you mr. Trump doesn't come close to
him when it comes to money or our Wow
power a power doesn't close you know yes
well I mean the guy wants to shut down
the government Jeff Bezos can't shut
down the government that is true okay
Jeff Bezos can't declare war no he
cannot here's the meet with Putin no he
does not
he might for other reasons yeah but not
not for world government stuff do you
think Jeff Peters be kidnapped if you
went on vacation Mexico with just one
security guy oh my god they would just
love it they would they would adore it
if Jeff pieces would come to Mexico yeah
now I want to do this on my own I gotta
clear my head yeah guys it's not about
money it's about the experience yeah
yeah don't trust me guys look if anybody
weird comes up to me I'll just talk to
them I'm a human being yes
people first yeah yeah of course they'll
understand yeah yeah look people in
Mexico use Amazon - I'm very very
popular yeah yeah you bet you are Jeff
it says the investigation into the leak
has not concluded and the team behind it
has yet to issue any formal statements
about it the fact that the texts ended
up at the Enquirer has fueled bees those
investigators suspicions that the leak
was politically motivated again so what
we were saying though was in terms of
people investigating you I'd much rather
have the government investigating me in
the Jeff Bezos investigating me yeah
he's gonna put a lot of energy and a lot
of money into it especially this one
boys yeah this is personal for him yeah
his tips are more than I'm making a year
his tips you know what he could leave as
a tip just for dinner just bad when the
greatest example a good example right
you're right yeah so I I and I also
think I think he'll get to the bottom of
it quickly
[Music]
Jim Jim may I ask you a question because
that was a strange outburst sure the
audio was strange for people too may I
ask you a question because I'm not sure
what happens try a text it has it hasn't
drifted over this way but I'm gonna Troy
is opening the door he's left his
position he's opening the door in
Fanning in I don't play I'm rich vos
actually removed himself from the
microphone and went over to the couch
Jim did you pass gas Jim did you break
wind be honest Jim did you break wind
it's like was it a bad one Jim I knew it
was gonna be how do you know I just felt
it in my gut I felt that my chest I see
this was this was toxins escaping from
yeah I think it text you sent me yeah
sent me a text apologizing in advance
wow you really so you know your body I
knew this was gonna be a doozy Wow gotta
become all in your yeah yeah by the
great story if you're done with that
story not a great one just a story oh
the dumb one but when you guys are ready
what's your story
oh two things I played golf with uh
what's the skinny so far yeah sorry
handsome Rob played golf with rich Voss
that's right [ __ ] kid you called me
rich called me we were talking on the
phone about shoes and he was like he was
like gotta go play golf
I gotta go play golf with handsome Rob
tomorrow I got to pretend I like this
kid for fall afternoon he [ __ ] this
little skinny [ __ ] kid hit the ball a
mile is that good unbelievable happy
gilmore unbelievable how far does kisses
guys who taught handsome Rob had a
brother get to pour 280 280 I mean he
tied weed how far can I thought you pull
a little bit to four I'm 230 made up to
40 to 30 probably there's lost a good
golfer yeah he's pretty good it's got a
great short game which of course he does
[Laughter]
by the way there's a nice ring oh thanks
but he [ __ ] clock the ball it was
amazing how far he I bet it until it he
was like the front nine I want in the
back now he was killed how far can tiger
hit the ball ah two blocks yeah I mean
it's less than a mile is probably 310
315 no you know what like to lady yeah
between 260 to 280 he can only hit it 30
that's almost all right you're almost as
good as Tiger Woods no close Oh nicely
yards no I mean he could hit like I it's
insane what he could do well how's
Rich's Drive it's okay he's got a that's
not what I heard you said I heard the
registered that Rob came back and
reported that Rich's drive was not good
don't know his swing is strange it's
really strange horses it goes back for
him
yep but now I fix I play I played like
nine out of the last 12 days back good I
get my swing back but then when I get my
weird swing I make it work for me yeah
what's your weird swing um sometimes
I'll loop you've got a like a much yeah
but but then when I when I'm swinging
you know sometimes it comes it goes it's
a game it's a hard game and sometimes it
you [ __ ] love golf
he loves it it's awesome it's so much
funny to me I take it Bonnie to play God
bigger money
but so [ __ ] good this guy yeah you
know did you guys do anything after
garbage to go get food or anything had
to talk in the parking lot you did a
small talk yeah did you do you think
that he would by the end of it he was
kind of looking after you a little bit
you did because you're so good I see it
was good and it's good to play if you're
playing golf you want to play with so
many it's good to say you play up to
their level you know if you're playing
with a bunch of crappy people it's hard
right to to concentrate you want to go
pick up chicks you go with Troy Kwan
because these are level if you want to
pick up chicks you go with somebody like
him so you look a lot better I say then
you're the [ __ ] fat girl so that
makes sense
you Norton is the three that the six is
hanging out with I understand okay I
can't even disagree that makes sense to
play with him is that exciting for you
rob
yeah I do golf buddy you do yeah now did
your dad ever get a little bit envious
because I don't know if I know there's
no one older than him I don't know if
you know this rich but it used to be
when Rob was younger right he and his
father would go out and play golf and
they'd have what's called dad and lad
time so you are actually becoming kind
of a paternal yeah figuring his life dad
and your business eyes about blowing
them you're filling in that role of dad
and lad time well you know what
sometimes dads aren't available it's
kind of like a foster kid you know
taking one in what do you think imagine
I'm the play on words yes what I do
you stupid father does your dad get
jealous that there's another older man
around that's a infringing on his dad
and lad time does let's be honest it
would be far more appropriate for us to
be playing golf with your dad sure
especially I mean I know you're an adult
yeah but you look even younger than you
are young
you look like a young charge like he's
an all yeah man you're like a young
escort and you're playing with an older
gentleman was paid for your company
right like it looks like all rich Voss
has a man-child that he hangs out now or
like a boy child you know so I couldn't
bring you around to the golf course
right maybe pay first round right let me
go help you look right yeah
was there any sort of check-in as honey
for ticks yeah it's just you worry about
grooming is what it's called you worried
about I'm worried about that you may be
being groomed no I'm an adult I always
forget that yeah yeah I know I look
young you sure yeah and you ever you
have a naivete about you I do you two
we're into Jeff no I brought my own golf
club okay what kind of golf clothes like
is it silly golf closer like a little
Angus Young outfit right shorts shorts
and a little schoolboy suit in the Hat
you think that's what rich would bring
for ya CK yes yeah yeah no they should
match next time we should yeah so your
dad doesn't get jealous that you're
having dad in lad time with another man
no this place
where's his place in a horse what you
call is it I think some of the top
courses in the country it's nice it's
pretty wait are you breaking Hall worth
I'm just saying you play dumb wherever
you want to get away that you could
never play like where could you never
get in Pine Valley where's that
South Jersey the best course in the
country is it really Jersey yeah sure
see you can't get in there is that true
Rob best course in the country it's one
of you Wow welcome usually won't say
exclusive can you go to merrill ago golf
course there's no golf course yeah okay
can trump get into Pine Valley where
they say no to him like sometimes
politicians they won't let him all date
Pine Valley turned down Clinton Wow
after he was president I think they said
we don't want to deal with the security
Nicola this is what I heard that's it
Mike please I didn't love a guy keeps
falling
this is what I heard that they told jack
nicklaus his wife has to wait in a car
can't this is years ago back in a day
that's what I heard so I heard Ben also
Clinton couldn't get on to say the hill
they're so exclusive look Augusta is so
exclusive one year when it wasn't the
sponsors everybody saying you have to uh
you know let let females join this and
that they said you can't tell us what to
do
[ __ ] you we don't need sponsors during
the Masters they pay for the Masters
without sponsors so four days on CBS
yeah it's great to pay four days the
sponsors come back eventually yeah well
they let Condoleezza Rice join there and
they just announced that they're having
a Women's Amateur tour term here how
often you play golf Rob I play a lot I
don't know probably during the spring
summer time at least twice a week what
about when it gets cold you gotta take a
break from the gamers are there indoor
spots or what I do there are indoor
spots you can play indoor like I know
simulated yeah simulator did you ever
fly to Florida do you think people ever
go to Florida to play golf it's actually
great a couple weeks ago where I was in
Miami working but I played so on the
road you'll get up at like 6:00 in the
morning play golf a bottle slow man I
don't smell it but I've been
desensitized that smell I don't know
what you're talking about on your way in
rich Ross told you the abominable
snowman I said slow man oh it's not a
bondable whatever when are we gonna just
realize stop correcting boss fat jokes
about me right now I'm just fat I mean
it's not we know yeah you look like the
Darth Vader when he took the mask off or
the thing on your head
his word is collapsing on the outside is
that warm its dude that garage son of
yes great for cars in oh yeah dude I'm
sorry yes
bob is a bandolier there's not a be
another this is this no it's just sling
just sling bandolier this is the sling
this is the coolest ever now to trap one
no yeah Ville right now yeah I'm gonna
ask you you want it just to have it you
don't know what cuz you got it
I don't you can see us to make it's free
I don't make some money off of it
[ __ ] money a little [ __ ] no you know
why I don't think you need money
look at all those rings thank you can
doing very well financially I can tell I
gotta ask you something yeah what we're
just wanting to move on no no after
after just something I gotta show you on
sneaker app what you want ask Bob where
do you get to swing from side cop what
is just like a knapsack right no so you
wear on your front oh yeah this came
with the laptop Bobby's milk pours right
into it why do you why do we colostomy
bag on the outside of your clothes in
the GUI just doing material last night
jokes and using them on us that's your
second string where'd you get it from a
company that you are a [ __ ] where'd you
get outta my company company yeah did
you buy your own no you can find these
along the road like
you just grab them it's like for tonight
where for Bob goes up I found a new item
no sigh cop said this bag company they
make backpacks too but they're like
travelers I think your account your
camera setup were class and I do to work
all that worries for not do it I could
have shot a special with that camera
that set up on material and then hit the
lead after I watched it when you get
taped I fail every time if I'm not
getting taped I I've had shows uh McGraw
that was it and then as soon as I put a
camera
Jasmine bumble everything yeah cause you
know it's happening it's uncomfortable
uh Fox News natural well Robert Kelley
and rich vos are here now for anybody
that didn't understand you're
apologizing yeah so you had trouble in
the parking lot coming in dude that
[ __ ] parking look I'm a lot you go
it's the one Sam told me about it's it's
super cheap is [ __ ] and you're really
good you might know is that you know is
inexpensive ways you're a [ __ ]
skinflint yeah but they do I've told you
about it they do this thing where it's
like it's a small area but they have
elevators but is to take all the cars up
most of the to more often than not one
of the two elevators isn't working they
go back and forth between which one
actually works but what happens in the
morning luckily that's the best part
about starting as early as we do that
usually there's no lime lined up for the
parking lot now but if you get there
after a certain factor 6:30 you're
[ __ ] you're waiting on a line of car I
was in a little traffic you know that's
the West Side Highway since I'll tell
you where it's but if you come if Ike if
see I didn't know what time to be here
cuz Rowland never gave me a time so I
asked rich vos and vos last night's at
eight o'clock right so I was listening
to you guys I was actually early I came
early like I've never been late right
and the fact that you guys compared
yourself to Howard almost made me throw
up
yeah who say wouldn't be late I would
sell out my nightmares I'm not gonna
sell out the first show Friday with this
show you've done you've done this 10
times stop your material the Sam so gory
can't pay attention
shut up yes stop with the old drunk you
come in you do material it's crazy
what's wrong I buy what what's wrong
what do you what is this I feel like
it's it's it's the 40's and I'm in
Germany right now pretty buddy what a
[ __ ] Jesus Christ no way might
override us no [ __ ] he's just so good
lies they get different good-looking way
you guys look good our sweater
he's like amateur okay you got tits done
yeah you look very [ __ ] Dutch sexy so
you're waiting what are you jealous you
look good too what's that don't hang out
soon any prayer that's what serenity
prayer
ah you know she eats it to you huh so
you're waiting for the parking lot can't
hit yes I hate it I don't you have to
wait for I waited for a good almost 20
minutes isn't it and you're just lined
up on the street they don't lined up on
the street no way I go yeah
hey - because people behind you would
get mad at you because you're in the
[ __ ] Street yeah and I shouldn't be
there but doesn't this you gotta just I
don't have that [ __ ] them Jean I have
just society and sorry for [ __ ] I
have no in-between Jean so it's it's
kind of which the earlybird there what's
the price for the earlybird 20s like 25
20 bottom line it's you're all 20 you're
all eighteen or twenty eight or but this
is right on 48 Vani bucks after-tax yeah
that's the difference
I'm on 50th are we really having this
conversation about rights conferred yes
four addresses and all this stuff let's
wait until I'm so hard you'll not have
to worry about this I mean I still have
a car but to driving into the city and
parking what a [ __ ] [ __ ] that was
it's not that bad if you do it at the
right time like for the starting at 7:00
yeah I get here like six six six between
6:00 and 6:15 every morning it's by
horrific yeah if I Drive takes thirty
minutes get here no question is the best
Chester better best Chester yes it's
best Chester lay on words
no it's just the [ __ ] you that's all
it's the best chest it's not you dirty
Jersey where you live on some cul-de-sac
right stop and then just that's it is it
a half-circle mom is it look like
Knott's landing
[Laughter]
he's just not sure if you mean not to
the K or an end yeah but coming in
around this coming in around this time
is a terrible time it's it was a wall if
you gotta come in from Jersey if you
like I don't I don't know I gotta leave
at like 5:00 a.m. to be to Toronto
you're stuck at the [ __ ] today that's
why Jersey stinks certainly someone good
thing about this new hour earlier is
that we it's way easier yeah Jersey I
would never move to Jersey no no because
of that traffic we have to come to the
city all the time [ __ ] that I came in
because I wanted to give you guys a half
an hour to to settle in you don't want
to come in late from the beach no you're
right I do you want to give us a half an
hour we can actually do the show and
then ruin it and then you ruin it for
the rest of it yeah I get that
it's so nice yeah it's good of you thank
you
you want to get them warmed up for you
you know I think they got it you don't
just jump in when I'm on the road you
don't run in at 7:00 and right places
you go in you know you do your time and
get some places you stay for a couple
hours you know that some still worse or
the five minutes stays what are you
talking I don't know Oh give us a little
fuzzy McGee
I don't meant the show I thought you
meant the show you didn't describe your
your what you're talking about those
five minutes spots when you're doing in
dela usually on like top 40 radio or the
news radio
they're the worst hey what do you wanna
talk about uh well they will record them
for five o'clock funnies oh I kind of
like them you do yeah because the guys
like all right Robert we got mr. Kelly
in studio today what a pleasure
we've seen you on tourgasm Louie's
brother
what's going on with Louie how's he
doing is he all right and then what do
you say I will let him know we're behind
I say yeah he's doing I would never say
that
why I would say he's got cancer so do
you work on like a like just like for
your own amusement do you work on a
character do you do yes come up with
ridiculous answer oh it's just very it's
very easy right deuce yeah man bright
dots awesome you to be enthusiastic not
funny no you could be funny you know
who'd be funny but you don't have to be
I was they laugh at everything because
they laugh at setup sometimes right
could you be like dude it's tough on the
road on the traffic that's all right
Robert Kelly same they just start giving
your dates to your material you can just
be unfunny on purpose and no laugh yeah
but that's what I mean like as long as
you have energy yeah you don't have to
be funny like you don't have to worry
about anything
yeah the worst is when you're reading a
[ __ ] resume because they don't know
all your shits from the 80s keeps
knocking into and he's been doing this
longer than all of us I know why don't
you put your [ __ ] heavy nothing you'd
understand you sound like a horse's ass
exactly any talk with horse's teeth
you've gotta put your [ __ ] headphones
on you do tell me mom I can hear you I
can hear
but the audience who pays 1495 Batman
here you thank you tickets
thank you Bob you're right do you
understand and he's been knocking into
the microphone every other same Z
everything boss says it starts with this
exactly I'm nervous I get that we're
nervous to just talk into the microphone
yeah headphone on if you can't if you
had the headphones on you'd hear that
you're not in the mic listen well it's
not fidgeting with when you're working
in a club yeah if the microphone is
working and in front of your face and
not falling every two minute I can hear
the stress do you mean the speakers that
are on that are loud so I in the monitor
onstage to hear myself right like
headphones that's right they're
monitored um even do the math before you
came up with your example Einstein
there's no math involved this party in
this [ __ ] how do you tighten it it
just keep try would you help him please
just tighten and bring it up bring it up
and tighten it and then it comes down
I'm turning it off for a moment so the
fidgeting okay thank you did we figure
that out welcome on radio welcome to
ready to man this is what you call thank
Detroit now used to okay that's what we
called it for the first half hour right
don't know injure breakfast smells like
most people's farts let's thank you when
Norton's farts smell like most people's
deaths it's exactly yeah its eggs and
mustard you love mustard I do you're
just a [ __ ] weirdo I like mustard on
every anything yellow cake
I wish if Mike wasn't working on that
one I just gather get some revved up
then he comes in with a hot one yeah you
gotta be excited for the weekend Bob why
Superbowl oh yeah we're gonna win we're
having the apparently a year ago they
were in the soup I started talking about
the Patriots the Patriots yes the
championship it was great last year I
started at the cellar the Super Bowl
party if I get interviewed just for a
second Jim I want you to know that you
eating on the air you do it quietly and
professionally yeah but what it's done
is Voss is unwrapping his food because
he thinks now it's allowed and he's
gonna be chomping into the microphone
because you're a bad example for and I
have my finger on the club button you
haven't you do it professionally and
nobody can tell ya boss does not have
the same ability was snitching school I
was okay I was but the teachers liked it
oh I would love to see you get [ __ ]
stabbed like in the yard for [ __ ]
Wratten why would you tag that we need
you to bring it home shut up why are you
staring at me now I don't want to have
that you can make some whatever food
joke you came out now
Machel sheriff's food that's one thing
he's really good at he's a general yeah
food share because he wants some of
yours so why are you staring at me stop
staring well you were talking about the
Super Bowl party oh and and and and it's
you know I started this me and Liz mhm
and apparently this year it's not the
Robert Kelly Super Bowl party at the
Comedy Cellar it's the Jim Norton
Keith Robinson Robert and I'm and Robert
Kelly yeah really yeah like Christopher
Walken in true romance yeah wake anyone
huh so somehow Norton it's no it's Jim
Norton's right why would you have a
Super Bowl party with your name on it
when you are a totally fake football fan
your name and you don't even watch the
game can't wait to you watch them start
Bob footballing I like it but I might
have got to stay for the whole thing
your names on it is [ __ ] he put his
name I might show up we'll see yeah
that's gotta be infuriating for you I
mean this is your team here and then
Voss calls me up and I'm telling him I'm
like [ __ ] Norton stuck his name on my
putt and he goes what about me no I'm
good I agree that Norton key to be on it
cuz tried to sell all the time and
they're they're you know they're there
five or six nights a week so they
deserve what kind of food are you gonna
bring to your party know whatever they
get I don't put any thought into it
you don't buy honestly did we need on it
can I tell you we're having Joe's pizza
we're having SAS you got like seven pies
last year this year and the people
stopped I stepped on that I apologize
cuz his sincerity is so real
yeah and then he just slips in his
[ __ ] evil who he really is joke he's
really good tricking you in the moment
of being like all bosses just having a
conversation
no no because I I got excited that I
really did get Joe's pizza but here's
last year and Joe's pizza to me is the
best in New York to me is the opinion by
the way there's beats in the best
Chester that's better but go on in
Mamaroneck no no way nothing Jose yes it
is no for what cuz you live out there
that's what you think cuz you don't know
you're not you don't have the culture
and have you ever known
[ __ ] Jersey that's true your act like
your culture I mean it's more than hey
I'm painful my father grew up into
you share a pool with your neighbor's
[Laughter]
backyard terrible come to the party but
because he mean many money know the
sound so is taking care of it so is is
the best yeah
liz is the best except when she puts
Norton's name on your party Wow she
caught I go what the [ __ ] is North she
goes what do you want me to make it I go
you know I just started laughing I go
you need to leave it now this is the way
you can't and that vas called her and
threatened her yelled at it Woodley say
I'm gonna start doing spots here vales
more she yeah you called her yelled at
her she could she told me she called me
trying to say she was hurting me what my
nothing it was getting under my skin
why because I wish there's a tumor what
she called her and she was a huge
hurricane you know you stop with your
mustard your [ __ ] mush is great
everything too much too much sugar
doesn't have that doesn't have a sugar
in it like so it's better to have
mustard that's great it's old man in the
porch Babel should just talk about it's
a girl you're funky man
that's nice - is it unsweetened I hope
you're talking about the phone call and
she called you and was rub it in but
then III SEC I gave it a second thought
I go
Noren and Keith deserve to have their
name on it because they are you know huh
I'm they do you have your name on it I'm
in there I've been there all the time
it's nobody will you leaving me what's
the junk name is still on it there's no
joke it's what it is they should have
the name on your right side your
shouldn't I don't need the pressure
cause if it bombs then this your party
now do you take hope the party bombs you
do oh yeah well we reformed do you take
it very seriously
like are you big Patriots fan I'm you
can get out stupid aha that's what
happens eat on the air yes without
exactly yeah you [ __ ] trash Jersey
guys I can wait
mouthful of food Ethel and nothing yeah
and rams are gonna win this one are they
I don't know I'm scared cuz there's a
ramp in but I really want to bet on New
England but it's hard to bet against
your team you know what I mean the Rams
not your team my whole life no they know
this is being rammed is see what that
should be your joke whoa why'd I do the
same joke it's okay we're jugglers
you're accurate we just slow in the room
down for a moment we'll get back there
yeah no problem I am I do take it
serious but not as serious as I you you
so you can actually be social and have a
party [ __ ] yeah last year when the
Eagles took us they [ __ ] mocked me I
was re a big J and like Vecchio
I had to pay money it was a [ __ ]
nightmare they were just screaming at me
it was but it was a lot of fun I don't I
don't care I'll probably go to it this
year I'll probably go put your names on
it yeah I remember James Jersey that's
all those guys it was fun yeah Jim hang
your party a lot of Philly acts here and
a lot of bull atif it yeah well
there was only two Boston people oh you
I think my meeting Gary there I don't
think Gary was in unless you know he was
away Lester wasn't hoping him he was
living in Boston I was the only Patriots
fed no yeah Joe list he wasn't there he
stays home he will not come out of his
house when the Patriots of the soup
that's asking is there people who take
it so seriously I want to go to a party
they want a game of Sal you know Sal
from Impractical Jokers right volcano
volcano is sweetest guy ever
he's throwing him he's [ __ ] us cuz
he's throwing a great bash we're at his
house well how come we won't invite us
that piece of [ __ ] well you have a party
with your name I'd go to Sal's in a
second well I'm sure he'll invite you no
he won't
everybody's going there a lot of the
young bucks of course I'll go in there
what do you think they're getting on
Impractical Jokers I don't have guests
huh Wow it's it's in Staten Island
that's the Dabu sit on top of a landfill
and watch a game I didn't know that yeah
yeah so it's gonna be good it's exciting
boss you coming yes right now you see
the Pittsburgh TV station that had to
fire a guy so Little Joe people get so
low I mean come on if you can't trust
the chyron writer to keep his opinions
out of it you kind of got a fire a
chyron writer for that there's no well
they were covering Tom Brady and they
were covering like you know he was doing
the rally before he left
sorry I just I can't the wave loss eats
I mean I'm a chubby guy right now he
eats like he's trying to get [ __ ] free
cocaine just why is he sucking a dick
first he just put he put the whole
marine in his mother like it was a big
fat [ __ ] and then twists it and pushes
it in as far as he can go
like he wedges it in his mouth and then
he bites down that pole the only person
watching other people eat out of
jealousy relax like awesome I have Sam I
apologize thank you you have back to the
facts yeah let's just let's just do
facts today I guess yes
look at the do we have it yeah this is
the video of the of the news this was in
Pittsburgh with a big big rivals of
course right rice patton oswalt in the
background know England Patriots
quarterback Tom Brady see the chyron
under it said Tom Brady and then right
under it it said known Jeter it's a
hilarious football due to Jones he's not
a serious thing and they fired the guy
who did that's they come how do you not
fire the guy who did it
maybe when you can't fire him you have
to suspend him moving your different
places my joke was a stupid you know
that was not even him that was the other
two guys going to do it do it it's in
brights part where they're [ __ ] that
holes they're obsessed with a football
somewhere there's a Jim and Sam at that
network going
do it do it do it I'll be hilarious so
he's so he's the guy who's like well I
just did it cuz I thought because I
wanted to see the other guy laugh yeah
he laughs and it makes me do bad Tommy
has no sense of humor either I don't
know I guess I don't somebody who go
yeah you should be fired like yeah I
don't know anything I don't I don't
really watch any Tom Brady interviews
you love Tom Brady Bob I remember you
were defending him making out with his
son he's easily in the top ten
quarterbacks of all time he's head save
these hot takes for your Super Bowl
party yes Jim yeah oh my god top five
yeah your mind no I put them behind
Montana on what Aikman and Fran
Tarkenton friend you like Fran Tarkenton
guy from the animal Archie Manning
strong Bradshaw
yeah and as he made out with his kid I
mean listen it was one second too long
okay alright Bank if you give you kiss
if it was just one second too long like
it and then the part where he goes is
that it you don't say that
voice right yeah and the massage part
yeah there was a couple things that in
fact is when anybody loves his kids
they're just all the context was was a
kid a son or a daughter a son no I was
just I was just sometimes your dumbness
is it's contagious yeah you're the
dumbest person I know is it a mirror no
what so you would are you invested in in
like you do you need them to win or you
don't need yeah I'd love to do it let's
say hi is he five in three or five and
402 Bulls he's uh five great five and
three okay you want to bet two hundred
you owe me I know I already gave you
that no you didn't I paid you you did
not I say what do you want and you said
no what did he owe you 100 for we been
on the lowest Gomez fight and I took
what Lily's comments fight he had that I
MMA match with some guy oh that's right
and nobody was betting betting so they
all wanted Luis to win so my decision
some actions I [ __ ] killed the kid
yeah it was a dumb bet on my part but
just there was no fun happening we were
out in front of the cellar right 20 of
us watching it on my iPad Pro know I bet
you before that wasn't deer watching him
with you I was it we bent like a day or
two but anyway yeah I was good it's
important to have those details in when
you're telling anecdotal story I wasn't
that can't remember that he told the
joke seven times yeah but he remembers
details like that right of course but
you don't like the deal interrupt a joke
story to give a real fact that's
annoying what I'm saying do you want to
bet the hundred you or me I'll bet it I
get three and a half no you know points
it's straight up Imam I'm not betting
without points I just [ __ ] [ __ ] I
don't go to draftkings bagus I said
thank you
does that bagels there Vegas I said
Vegas no Vegas
you said Vegas Vegas like that's what
they say when you say can you pay me
from a show
I like it that was a stretch but I know
I was a second but I once I got a point
no you don't with friends no we're not I
got two Rams and I take the Rams three
nothing that's I think I said that
measure no you did of course I did
because you know I said it no I didn't I
originally said I didn't listen to bank
and the guy came around with the mic
yeah
and he asked who do you think originally
I said the Chiefs 17 nothing because I
forgot that they were not in this rule
uh-huh and then I said III amenda Ram so
you know there should be a big cowboy
fan yeah I know
you quit football I watch mostly UFC I
don't really care about it any of it
anymore I just don't know why same thing
I'm Bennington I can't I don't want to
give out Bennington just [ __ ] you know
until he comes out with this prediction
so I'm not gonna I'll tell you off the
air but that's one of his [ __ ] I'm not
gonna blow it before he goes off a
minute ago you just said it you didn't
just say it
[Laughter]